[Music]
a metal worker clamps the disk against a
form in a lathe as the lathe spins he
presses the dish to the form using a
blunt tool
this transforms the disk into a flared
vessel one that looks like a flower pot
a cutter at the side trims the rim they
call this flower pot shape the draft a
worker presses the spinning draft to
another form this stretches the aluminum
shape longer and narrower finally they
tape for the cylinder at the top to form
a slanted chimney and slice off the
bottom he drills a hole in the gradient
of the kettle he inserts a screw that's
attached to a punch then using an allen
wrench he turns the screw forcing the
punch into the metal to cut out a hole
for the kettle spout
[Music]
he now slides the kettle body over a
post with a die that fits into the spout
hole he places the spout over the die
and hammers it into the hole next the
inner wall of the Gilly kettle takes
shape wielding a tool with force
a worker pulls and stretches the
aluminum disk into a long cone
[Music]
he inserts the cone in the kettle body
the gap between them will serve as the
water chamber and smoke will be vented
out the center he rolls the upper lip of
the cone around the kettles top rim
locking them together
he also secures them at the base the
same way
he transfers the Gili cattle to a stand
to keep it upright as he rivets steal
ears to it the ears are for attaching
the handle and a chain for the kettle
whistle the base of the Gilly kettle is
this fire chamber for packing purposes
he stacks it upside down and places the
kettle over it he wraps the entire
kettle and British newsprint for
shipping this protects it and also gives
the purchaser something to burn the
first time he or she tries it out he
crimps the ends of the handle to the
ears that protrude through the headlines
he places the whistle over the Raps
pound and then tucks the kettle into a
drawstring tote